[Music]
and it's an honor a blessing in a dream
to welcome in in my mind the greatest
running back in the history of the
Philadelphia Eagles Brian Westbrook not
uh not a blessing and a dream it is it's
both of those things I appreciate that
lashauwn is up there yeah juice is up
there first of all
shout out to deuce I'm watching the
Eagles game and the development of him
as a coach on that team from the
beginning where I was like holy crap do
Stanley as a headset on to now I'm like
he looks like he's belong there forever
and he's getting closer and closer to
being a head coach you think he's gonna
get a chance you know it's hard to go
from a running back coach to a head
coach it really really is hard and
that's why he was pushing so hard to
become that offensive coordinator yeah
because obviously that's the enemy
absent the enemy still trying to prove
it with the Chiefs are it's hard well
let me just imagine they devalue the
running back position I was gonna say
and why would they value the coach yeah
and so for him he has to begin to call
plays and obviously the per question for
most people is quarterback coach you
develop some talent then offensive
coordinator right when you were in the
locker were you like oh this guy could
be a coach one day you know what I mean
I never thought that he could be a coach
yeah but I always thought like you know
deuce knows his things and he he
understands it on a different level it
just wasn't the X's and O's forever it
was all about this is why we do this and
this is this and this is bad Young Buck
listen to me young buck just listen
don't do that I mean he was one of those
guys in and I love deuce I mean I
remember my first day there where I
practice I had no clue what I was doing
I'm not just running around just trying
to do something fast yeah but but deuce
was like listen slow down and remember
this just take care of number five if
you if you just block for number five
you're halfway there you're good yeah
and and believe it or not that's what it
was just go figure out how to block and
the coaches will believe in you at some
point
juices pickle juice came was the
greatest thing ever buddy Lee that's
what we used to call him buddy Lee I
mean dude here's the thing about doing
people that don't know a pickle juice
was
my first game I think it was like 2,000
Andy Reid kicks an onside kick in the
first game of the year against the
Cowboys and they go on to win like 41 to
14 yeah and they kept showing deuce
Staley on the sidelines drinking pickle
juice because it was really really hot
but they're down in Dallas and he had
like a hundred and fifty yards rushing
or something like they're down in Dallas
on that turf and you know the sun's
coming down yeah the little hold in the
center and he sounds like on the turf
like it outside it was a hundred degrees
but one the turf they said it was Ray's
E and so guys to stay hydrated it's
[ __ ] drinking pickle juice this is
how much of an eagle okay so we have so
much to talk about today it was the
first week of preseason games which it
was great to have football back even if
it was for like one drive at a time
sucked it did like but then again like
seeing Sam Darnell go down the field and
go while Chris Hernandez and Crowder is
nice and then I turn on the the the
Browns and I see Baker Mayfield and
they're running a two-minute offense
because that's what Freddie kitchens
once and and then like all of it felt
really good
the a B saga the Zeke saga the Melvin
Gordon thing continues we're gonna get
into all that I think that Tuesday is
one of the biggest days ever in the
history of hard knocks and then the
show's been going on for 13 14 years it
could end tomorrow night why I will
explain that let's start right there a
B's drama yeah holy crap there was one
point I went on the pro football talk
this weekend and the first seven stories
all had a Antonio Brown in the title
which means two things one it's crazy
and two that's how much people care
about a Antonio Brown we've had the
mustache this offseason he holds the
team hostage then he goes to Oakland
shaves it off gets an enormous contract
then he cryogenically freezes off the
bottom of his feet and now what happened
over the weekend was he's had a helmet
for ten years a decade it's been really
like not usable according the NFL for
like two or three years and he's having
a fight in
with with lawyers with the NFL to keep
wearing a helmet and and Brady and
Rogers and all these other people are
having to give away the helmets to and
he's fighting it and it's it's what was
your thoughts as this weekend was
progressing well first of all I'm gonna
start here I don't think that they
should have allowed him to had to have
that helmet for ten years if they're
talking about is outdated that helmet
was discontinued in 2011 unbelievable
and they allowed them for the next eight
nine years to play with that helmet did
you have a favorite helmet or anything
like that it's funny because I'm
thinking about this story and as a
player you're you're a creature of habit
right
socks put my socks on this way my
wristbands my my shoulder pads
everything and part of that is having
the second equipment thigh pads knee
pads if you wear them ankles or all
those different things you're a creature
of habit and a helmet was a big part of
that and a big part of the the OTAs and
things like that is getting used to rain
pads again we're getting used to your
helmet again and it was for me it was
always the same fit I want the same fit
I'm ready same feel because I don't want
to have to worry about any of that no
and I get on the field the only thing I
want to worry about on the field is
getting ready to play and excuse what
you're looking for apps you don't you
don't need a trainer go and by the way
your favorite tape right now I don't
have it anymore it's not as adhesive
like hey no no I don't want to hear any
of that I just want to be able to focus
on football the other part to this
helmet thing is that there's certain
look that goes willows helm aesthetic
matters and I'm trying to tell you and I
saw it at the tail end of my career they
started changing the facemask they go in
these different shapes and they look
totally different I have said for a long
time the I think it's visas those the
new helmets they are I used to say man
they're the best helmets for protection
you should wear them but they're also
freaking enormous yes any antonio's
helmet is like almost like fits the
skull perfectly which is why it's not
safe but well it here's the other thing
so my last year in Philly out there
eight years my last year I had two
concussions right so I'm coming back for
my second concussion in that same year
which is kind of crazy yeah and they
were like we got to put a different
helmet on you and so as a player I'm
like I mean I didn't buck the system
because I wanted to play
I don't have thirty million dollars
guarantee yeah like Antonio Brown but I
wanted to play so it was important for
me I don't care what type of helmet they
gave me but in because I wanted to play
that was my game I wanted to finish my
career in Philadelphia and play football
so when they came back they came with
this huge helmet in and I know and one
of his one of his complaints Antonia
Browns complaint yes it's too big I
can't see and I understand exactly what
he's saying because you want a light
helmet that you can move around you tell
them what small yes that's what you want
as a player and so they come with this
huge helmet extra padding trying to
protect your head and things like that
which is kind of crazy because in
reality football is just a hard sport to
play physically because of your head
right and so they come with this big
helmet and I felt out of place I felt
completely out of place you felt a
different player I felt like of course
it's like wearing new new new shoulder
pads well you've had the same shoulder
pads for the last ten years
it's for a regular person it's like
wearing shoes that are already broken in
versus wearing brand new shoes and
walking a mile in what your feet are
gonna hurt it's gonna feel different
gonna feel weird what's incredible to me
though is Antonio was told multiple
times that this was gonna happen
yeah and instead of spending the
offseason adjusting and getting used to
it it sounds like he thought no I'll do
what I've always done and just do what I
want right and that's that's where it
becomes like everyone else is changing
and and it kind of has to for like
liability but then for Antonio Brown to
fight it I had to think I like to do
this when everybody is going one way how
can I argue the other way so everyone's
saying that Antonio Brown is demanding
too much there's a little bit crazy but
what if Antonio Brown is right what
could it be and what I thought about was
you know what nobody talked about this
weekend Antonio Browns feat and I'm just
gonna say that Antonio Brown may have
prevented himself from like being really
effective for the first two months of
the season because the bottom of his
feet are destroyed and now all we're
caring about is him having to wear this
old helmet and no one's talking about
his feet anymore it's crazy because most
most teams if you're in the team sport
the coach will say you know what
we're having a bad bad couple games I'm
gonna be the distraction take the
attention off of you right in a weird
way Antonio Brown has taken the
distraction
yes he's distracted to everyone to take
away the the emphases offered the the
ideas authors his feet which is careless
I mean these are your money makers that
was reckless that's ridiculous
if I'm John Rooney not I have to give
John and Gruden some credit yeah he
stood in front of that doggone
microphone in that in that and the media
and he said I support him yeah he wants
that home and I support him in support
support support now he has to do that
right because he paid him a bunch of
money thirty million bucks guaranteed he
was a god thing to do is start
alienating and turning around already
absolutely before you even see him on
the field but at the same time come on
me really Antonio Brown come on brother
what I want you to do here's the thing I
don't want Antonio Browns career to die
on the hill of a helmet just say well
this is the helmet I wanted I can't and
I can't wear it because then I'm gonna
throw a fit because I can't do what I
want
he's too good of a player for that but
but I'm what I'm saying is if he goes
I'm not playing and really the reason
he's not playing is because his feet I'm
just saying it's like very interested
Antonio Browns career before a little
bit to Chad Johnson in this regard
people forget that when Chad Johnson put
on that Hall of Fame jacket after a
touchdown he was on path to go to the
Hall of Fame like half of us were like
that's really cocky the other half or
like well he's kind of on his way there
and and Chad Johnson went and he had
that one tumultuous offseason where the
domestic violence charge in Miami and it
was something crazy offseason that threw
everything off and Antonio Brown is
pretty much stride for stride year by
year of productivity their numbers are
very similar and they're right around
the same time where this is when he went
to a new team and it all kind of
collapsed and I know Chad Johnson had
the year in New England where it didn't
work and he was gonna go Miami but my
thing with Antonio Brown this offseason
like people are talk about he might
retire I could see it all swirling out
of control and it really frightens me
because
he's been if I if I gave you a million
dollars to predict what's gonna happen
with Antonio Brown next I don't think
you can do it don't you think that it's
erratic but don't you think the Jon
Gruden see be like hold on let's let's
get this thing back in control we got
barfi we got I think he's the worst
coach to try and reel something in
because he's also gonna want to go out
there and say something
well yeah but at some point you got to
be like all right guys this has to be no
this is what wittily raid would do it at
some point
any reasonable I will well I thought he
would and I tell you got spiraled out of
control with tio and yeah this thing but
it's some point you gotta say all right
let's get back to football because to me
now this is out to listen to Jon Gruden
in the boo for ten years yes I'm
thinking he's gonna say all right guys I
only want you guys focused on football
and this isn't football yeah but it
seems to me that on this team out there
in Oakland he's like okay cool we will
support them and because you need them
so this is why I think Hard Knocks is
either going to go to another
stratosphere or it's gonna end on
Tuesday night we have wanted for 14
years however long the show has been
going on we have always wanted a team
that has great storylines and all the
characters and this is the perfect mix
it's it's not a run-of-the-mill like
four and twelve Carolina Panthers team
it is the Oakland frickin Raiders with
Jon Gruden and vantes perfect and Richie
incognito and Mark Davis and Derek Carr
and Antonio Brown and they're moving to
Vegas it's the perfect storm and we know
that Hard Knocks takes a week to do that
to do their next episode and they
typically are done two days beforehand
this happened in the window it happened
on a Thursday and a Friday this didn't
happen on a Monday say I'm on a Sunday
so they're gonna have ample time to take
us behind the scenes of what's happening
if on Tuesday night they gloss over it
and I'm watching two rookies go bowling
together and I'm watching a third-year
linebacker changing diapers for the
first time Hard Knocks has done that's
how I feel about me they're gonna lose
all credibility they're not given the
real inside looking vana I'm gonna think
it's just state TV yeah that the Raiders
have taken all creative control
and they've limited all and it will
never be the same and we've it's jump
the shark do you think that's gonna
happen cuz it's my biggest fear I think
that they go they have to dig deep into
that I I somebody got up somebody said
to me it feels like a new style of hard
knocks we're not getting the the
seven-minute intros anymore with the
crazy graphics we're not getting like
the driving up we got right into it last
week they stir the first shot of last
week was an Antonio Brown that's right
if I don't get all Antonio Brown right
now what do you want to hear you want to
hear behind the scenes Antonio Brown
walking into grutas office like yo my
feet hurt and I'm not wearing this
helmet I need access with an Antonio
Brown
I need John Gurdon on the phone like
rubbing his temples being like what's
the issue it's a helmet now like I need
I need people in the locker room talking
about it I need Liv Schreiber going like
while his issue is his feet there's more
afoot with Antonio Brown like I need
like I I need the segment I need all of
it I want to see Antonio Brown running
onto the field with the old Steelers
helmet that he spray-painted
Oakland that was such a good part of
Mike's silver that it made it San
Antonio Brown was painting the helmet
himself raising he's got like his little
kids with like if that put they put that
on Hard Knocks so you were on a team
with tio
yeah and tio I think looking back at it
like Antonio has been erratic tio it
made sense you understood why he was
doing what he was doing was fighting for
him he was fighting for a contract
guarantee right Antonio already has the
money yeah so now it's all this other
stuff but what is it like when there's
one personality that seemingly is a
magnet what is that like for everybody
else so you have to go back to o for -
yo gets there and now he came in the off
season it was kind of messed up with
Baltimore in a trade right it kind of
and the Niners designers yeah that came
together I would say late there was an
arbitrator that had to rule that there's
on a summer so it kind of came together
and as a player I was about going to my
second year I was probably the most
excited guy there because I knew his
talent yeah right and you saw what he
was doing on the west coast him he was
amazing best receiver in the game at the
time but
we also heard there's a stigma coming
with this guy that you know some people
thought he was a team record he's a
coach records a locker room record he
just couldn't help you and they say that
about a b2 and they say that but you
can't deny that talent no when you see
that type of talent in my mind that's
all I wanted Andy Reid has to deal with
all that other stuff that's his job my
job is to make sure that when he gets on
the field is gonna work and so that type
of talent comes in your tenure you're
absolutely happy and I was ecstatic to
get him then we go to Lehigh and you've
been you've experienced Leon yes what
we're talking about 40,000 people coming
to watch a summer practice coming to
watch to Italy like in Andy Reid ran
practice like a grown man
we're gonna hit we're gonna tackle to
the ground yeah he's gonna do three ones
versus ones where everyone's tackling
swear you know everything and so tio
came and we saw practice and so I had
the ability to see in my first couple
years and then when tio came right and
my first couple years practice was good
people the fans supported when tio cane
it was tio tio I mean it was the fans
were going crazy everyone was following
them obviously we went on to have a
great year
Theo you know did his think angels for
years everybody like no offense to James
Thrasher Todd pink so he was just
different every year it was when are we
gonna get a receiver for Donovan it was
always this thing yeah
conversely I compared that the opposite
idea was great that first year the
second year I literally watched the day
that tio did the sit ups in the parking
lot I was in a trainer I wasn't healthy
at the time I watched him argue with and
Erie right there in front of everybody
that's what caused it argue me like like
going back and signing autographs it was
it was it was terrible and so this is
how I was raised up in the system
you coaches are the coaches their job is
to coach you don't really question them
you may suggest different things but the
coaches the coach you respect that and
there's a lot of guys and not just tio
they just didn't think that he thought
you can go back and forth with the coach
and and and II just didn't believe in
that right and so he kind of went back
with teal because of course he
recognized the talent and then he just
threw him out and then you talk about
attention to y'all went home back to his
house and had a whole media scrum yeah
at his house
he's outside to meet shirt off doing
sit-ups I mean it was to me now now
we're in camp
so it's enough for you we're watching
this in camp like wow I'm just because
this is what the Raiders are doing right
now that's what this active do they're
they're looking at every tweet and
everything that comes out and they're
like so you know what these guys are
going well here's the thing that they
probably will realize as the season goes
on it's impossible if there's at this
same attitude the same whatever or
around this team continues it's
impossible to win really impossible well
just think we had it we went to the
Super Bowl the year before we were we
played a bunch of games without tio that
year right playoffs Andy at the end of
the regular season we won without T I'm
not saying that you know we could have
won the whole season without our cuz
he's special talent but we won a lot of
games before tio got there
and then after tio was injured in you're
looking at Oakland right now you're
saying well first of all you guys didn't
win a bunch of games last year you're in
a really tough division I mean there's a
bunch of good teams in that division you
have a quarterback that you're still
trying to figure out if you're gonna
give him a long-term what did you mean
by it was it's impossible to win well
distraction my point is this you have a
lot of those things against you Division
oh my stuff yeah that's not true it's
impossible because to win in this league
you have to have everybody going in the
same direction you can't have half the
locker room question is your quarterback
good enough you can't have the have the
other half of the locker room saying the
it's the wide receiver versus everybody
it's Gruden versus Antonio Brown right
it's perfect versus the defensive
coordinator you can't have that when you
have those types of distractions in a
game like football yeah well you need
all 11 guys at going in the same
direction doing the same thing at once
if you have one guy doing something
totally different it messes up
everything and and I literally
experienced it we had a good team you
just do it a good team yeah and we ended
up doing I think six and ten that year
because we couldn't stay focused because
we had so many behind the scene things
going on in the middle of the year Andy
Reid kicks to you off the field he kicks
him off the team
Wow he suspends them for a week and then
after that he ends up suspended him for
the rest of the season there was so much
internal fighting which I had to believe
at some point now here's the thing that
I think is going on going on in Oakland
I think in Oakland a lot of the
player support Antonia Brown because of
his skill set I know they do
I talked to a few guys on that team and
a few of them have said to me in the
past one his work ethic like naturally
gets everybody on his side yeah like
I've heard it from Trent Brown and
Jonathan Abram and all these guys were
there like when you see him work out
you're in a Antonio Brown same thing but
to you same exact thing exactly the same
same thing also he brings with him a
culture of winning yep they don't have
that in the Raiders and they they
couldn't get over the hump in
Philadelphia so they kind of rely on
that a little bit but now well he's also
their big-money free agent and he's
getting paid the most it's it's gonna
it's because he is gonna have people
that are gonna support him no doubt
about it
and that's the problem in the locker
room so let's just say this there were a
lot of people whether Donovan McNabb was
right or wrong with some things we kind
of all just went wrong with the program
it darling was right most of the time
and I'm not talking about you know he
wasn't doing anything crazy but we
supported our quarterback right and so
when we had teo come in and everyone all
bad we had half the room supporting
donovan because they were having a
problem with each other right the other
half supported teo because all those
things you just met he works hard he
brings it he's a winning talent the best
in the league what's interesting now
with interna brown though it's not a
Antonio Brown versus Gruden yet no it's
not a Antonio Brown versus Derek Carr
yet it's an Turner Brown versus the
league where he hasn't practiced yet
either one time yeah could it be when
you saw his feet did you think that he
could like how does that impact his game
well from someone that can cut on a dime
from everything that I've heard is that
he can run straight and we saw him
practice that me look good in that one
practice yeah obviously in anybody's
gonna look good one day when he goes on
the market chatter and so he can't cut
and that's his game that's all of his
game if you take you know and Tony
Browns 510 180 pounds maybe if you take
his ability to stop on a dime and go
left to right laterally you take that
away then he's just a guy he doesn't
have the straight line speed that I had
no no no and so that changes in the
other thing and this is the the psycho
part of the the the being a player when
you take away what I do great like for
me and I saw this towards the end of my
talk
when you take away my speed being able
to get to the outside now I get hit in a
different way now instead of getting hit
by the cornerback I get hit by the
linebacker that says now my back sir I
get hit by the defensive lineman it's a
whole different where you get hurt much
faster number well but it also changes
the way you think about yourself and so
and your mind you're like I just can't
do it anymore I also think about this
Jon Gruden on Hard Knocks last week when
I Antonio Brown he was like he's like
hey man you got chill man and it turned
him round like I need to take it up and
Jon Gordon looked at another coach and
said when he's out here he elevates
everybody else no doubt about it if a
Antonio Brown if it's injury lingers the
helmets lingering he will deflate the
team just as much as he was elevating
them by being out there because they all
thought we're having Derek Carr and
Antonio Brown and Tyrell Williams and
we're gonna get this new offensive line
going but if the main guys not there I
feel like it's deflating well I think it
weighs you down I mean because because
what happens is when the main guy is not
there when tio wasn't there for us we
had to answer all those questions that
they wanted so they the question stop
being about the Philadelphia Eagles it
started being about well what's wrong
with Donovan and teal life's pretty much
over a place absolutely it's an LJ Smith
how are you gonna make up so you're
right it does weigh you down
and I think the same thing is gonna
happen out there eventually Oh retiring
because they haven't even played the
game yet I'm letting you know that this
is going to become Antonio Brown versus
Jon Gruden and he's going to become
Antonio Brown versus Derek Carr because
all three of those people have one
problem they know where the camera is
and they all play to it Derek Carr was
all over the cameras and hard knocks and
when he did an interview on the cylon
the preseason game he says when I'm
playing Warren Sharpe with this online
when I'm playing I like to see what the
defensive coordinators trying to do and
take advantage and I'm like you are so
cocky right and you are not that good
no offense there's no reason to be that
way right Jon Gruden is he biting his
tongue right now and we're applauding it
which means he will not be able to do
that much longer he's eventually gonna
get frustrated because what is Jon
Gordon's baby the offense and if a
Antonio Browns not there you're hurting
his baby Derek Carr has already been
paid and he's where did he move his
house next to in Vegas Brian Westbrook
ruined neck
to Gruden so you know eventually he's
gonna go it would be great if Antonio
Brown was here something innocuous and
something that's simple is gonna make
Antonio Brown gonna go live on Instagram
or live on Facebook and he's gonna say
some stuff and it's going to erupt don't
you think that's Gruden's job though
part of it head coach's job where you go
that's your job I know
literally I mean of course he's the
offensive guy according to offense you
bring different plays and you're
designing things you're bringing into
the right players but the probably the
biggest part of your job
it's a managed personalities he couldn't
do it with Keyshawn Johnson they had to
trade him so his same coach say on it
too why would you if you couldn't do it
you get rid of Keyshawn why would you
bring in someone like a Antonio Brown
why would you do that because you know
that coaches go suck it happen on my
watch
yeah well I also want to know about this
people have tracked it back to when
Antonio Brown got hit in the playoff
game by van tez Burfict and now they're
teammates yeah they've they've looked
back and since then is when all of the
odd actions and do you believe that
there could be a connection between the
two i someone who's been concussed
obviously I've been that I've not
actually did a lot of research on it at
the time and a lot of this study said
that it's usually not that quick so that
was maybe what three four years ago most
of the studies when you start talking
about concussions they're saying the
early onset forties right mid 40s or so
45 or so into your 50s yeah so for it to
for him to have that situation we're
Burfict three four years ago
in for to do start to display yourself
in this way right it's a little the
other part is if it's going to display
yourself it's all the time it's not our
picking and choosing whether I want to
do crazy things and things that don't
make sense it's all the time not not
just when it's convenient to me
that's that that would be the argument
against that it's it's so interesting to
watch to Pittsburgh where Ben
Roethlisberger's comparing Ryan Switzer
to Julian Edelman and I'm watching James
Washington in the preseason game and he
looks
ten times better than he did his rookie
season I feel awful that Pittsburgh just
lost their wide receiver coach yes I
mean think about all the storylines that
are in rates wined by these two cultures
right now but I Antonio Brown it's it's
fascinating because he's one of the
greatest wide receivers of all time he's
one of the greatest characters that
we've seen a six-round pick that comes
out of nowhere and becomes like the tork
guy and he's on the cover of madden and
it was a Super Bowl winner and and then
this development it just proved to
everybody man everybody wants to leave
her there at just think about it before
you go man cuz change is craziest grass
is not always listen they haven't played
a game together but I have to believe in
Antonia Brown 15 touchdowns last year so
he produced without levy on bill
I still had a very strong running attack
you still had a Hall of Fame quarterback
throwing you to football hey know do you
have a strong running attack and I also
had Mike Munchak Hall of Fame offensive
line coach it makes a big difference
and now he's in Oakland there you go old
Miller well here's a deal do you have a
good running attack now questionable
questionable they just lost they just
lost Gabe Gabe Jackson for a weeks well
the best old lineman do you have a
quarterback that's gonna be a Hall of
Fame type of guide like no been nothing
close we're not even close in quite
honestly is that system that Jon Gruden
that's many people say it is outdated
from years and years ago is it the same
type of system that's gonna get you over
100 balls every single season for the
next six years so again the grass is not
always greener on the other side no
sometimes you got but at the same point
if you ain't gonna pay me I got it go
yeah exact what Antonia Brown was he so
he really he didn't care about singing
I'm gonna use that to transition to
Gordon and Zeke over under ten games
played for Zeke this season over over
under one game for Melvin Gordon Melvin
Gordon listen I that's where I feel like
Melvin doesn't play Melvin Gordon is in
that terrible situation terrible and
here's why it's terrible
Melvin Gordon has oftentimes been
injured in his career he's and I don't
know if he's ever played 16 games
you might have play 15 right and so this
is what I think about Melbourne Court
it's super super talented big strong
physical quick nice lateral movement can
catch the ball out of the back 16 and 20
17 and that's it that's it
14 13 and 12 that's not terrible but I
mean he probably could a place it was
like track record of missing he misses
some games so I think he is athletic
I think he's big I think he can run with
power I think he can make you miss I
think you can get outside and use speed
yes yeah and he had a hundred and eight
catches the last two years punch of his
first night here's the thing they have
two guys Austin echo
Justin Jackson yeah that actually had
some playing time last year when he was
injured and they did pretty good
yeah that's the difference and maybe
even more here's a bigger difference
that offense is built around Phillip
Rivers throwing the ball down the field
to Mike Williams throwing the ball down
the field to Antonio kzb still playing
football
yes Keenan Allen throwing the ball
that's what that offense is about now
conversely when you thought especially
when you think about Phillip Rivers in
the two-minute drill yeah he's not
running at all they're not worried about
Melvin Gordon they're worried about two
guys that can back him up that backed
him up for the last couple years and
they'll do good they paid Travis
Benjamin hunter Henry is back yeah
they're good now conversely when you
talk about Zeke it's a different story
powder maybe he's good Toni powder maybe
he's maybe who knows her over here
compared him to Alvin Kamara close you
guys need a stop you guys brought back
Alfred Morris and I think however Moore
was Morris was playing when I was
playing he was and I'm not listen he
runs hard but he's not a starting
caliber running back in the NFL and he
weren't here for a game three and for a
team that is literally built around the
run game unless you're telling me that
that can go win you football games then
you're making a huge mistake
so you think Zeke do you think Zeke gets
a deal before the season I think Zeke
gets a deal next week you do I do
okay here's the thing I think and I
think Jerry's been around football
enough to understand that it's gonna
take you a couple weeks to get in game
type of shape right so you can be ready
in this league and it did take Zeke
about a week or two when he came back
last time who knows what he's doing in
cop I hope he's having a great time me
too because I'll tell you what I wish I
was in Cabo right now so we should be we
should be watching the show so so in my
mind it's gonna take him a couple weeks
just to get up and running get them
going it's so important for them to get
a home-field advantage
you can't you can't I mean listen I'm
not saying that they have a hard
schedule the first quarter of the season
because I don't think it is but you
can't risk losing any of those games I I
think that what's interesting is that
first game they play the Giants yeah and
my thought is is they're gonna watch
sake one golden rays nuts right and
they're gonna look back at their own
running backs and they're gonna look at
Tony Pollard and they're gonna go we
know what we could be with Zeke Zeke
really it like I know that everyone
talks about the devalued running back
position and you were saying that it's
somewhat close between Melvin Gordon and
Austin Eckler Zeke is such a different
runner and an athlete that everybody
else involved and he's a tone setter he
destroys a defense over a game
demoralized them literally but I'm
fascinated at the fact that Zeke is gone
pretty much radio-silent other than the
one statement that Joe Xena Andersen
went with which is like he's willing to
miss games and a member of the Jones
family speaks about this every single
day
yeah and they it's being reported that
dak Prescott turned down an offer for 30
million dollars a year again is that
guaranteed is that regular nobody no
there's no cops and they just keep
releasing information and I just think
it shows that they're desperate and
they're trying to win the public but
everybody knows what Zeke's worth well
and I don't think he's gonna fold this
is what mean if I'm Zeke you saw what
happened with lady out there and listen
and this is one of the things that I
always preached about Lebanon by a bail
situation he's gonna get 400 carries
last year in Pittsburgh who knows what
happens to his body after that now the
year before before he set out
he played injured running backs are
always hurt every single game every
single week so you don't know what this
man felt like I know what I felt like
after giving getting 250
run rushes and then 100 catches I know
what my body felt like I can't imagine
being getting 350 carries Zeke had 322
carries last year in 77 receptions
that's what Zeke had he had almost
ginger plays of impact yes in to me
dears why it doesn't make sense your
team is built around that and if you can
tell me that you know you were willing
to let Emmett's it 92-93 well yeah
that's because you had a Hall of Fame
quarterback Troy Aikman you don't have
that right now
you haven't dad hasn't proved that he
can be there you get yourself a new
offensive coordinator you get yourself a
new quarterback coach job but we don't
know if we got a new coach and we don't
see me on the field so modak is he that
guy that can carry the load yeah can he
carry an offense we don't know that you
haven't seen a do it yet it's
fascinating because all of the contracts
are linked together Amari dak Zeke and I
always throw in Byron Jones because I
think Byron Jones is phenomenal that's
right but I look at Zeke and he is the
face of that team to me
and I know that Gerry Jones's desire to
win a Super Bowl is so big that he will
be his downfall in this negotiation
football Gerry is gonna go
hey money Gerry I want to win games he's
always said in they decided a couple of
times Stephen Jones has said it a couple
of times we don't want to set the market
okay Zeke has two years left and so the
important part about that is yeah you
have one year left as a player you have
some leverage really with two years left
you really have zero leverage right
there getting a do they don't need to
tear it up the only leverage that you
have is to withhold services that's the
only leverage you have which is which he
said he's willing to do yes which is the
only reason why he hasn't said more
there's nothing of me to say yes I said
I'm not coming so do I get a new
contract so so if you're Jerry Jones you
don't have to set the market you don't
have to and I don't think Zeke and I
think in a heart of hearts he has to
understand the business side of it you
don't need to set the market listen Todd
Gurley is getting what fourteen million
a year you give them elves getting left
hands getting 13 13 you give them 13.5
and then with incentives if you make the
Pro Bowl if you get over a thousand
yards right then that bumps you up so
you didn't set the market like you said
you weren't gonna do but you also made
your guy happy
and most importantly small windows in
this gang so you don't think Dallas
could be successful if she doesn't play
this year no way so when I hear people
say it's really built around Zeke you
believe so much so that like he's gone
and it goes from like a ten win team to
what I would say is six or seven wins I
think Zeke is are different between two
and three games there's no doubt about
it no my which which could mean the
division you can win or lose a division
won't get home field advantage and now I
say all that in the context that if that
comes back and he's Drew Brees right
then Zeke is an afterthought right you
don't need that you don't need a guy
that's gonna get 322 carries we can
split it up between this group of
running backs and we can say okay you
get your 100 carries you get 100 carries
and hopefully we someone else we'll
figure it out and we'll just all mix
match these guys together and get a
decent running back it's interesting
there's a there's a lot of young
quarterbacks that I think are in
situations that I find interesting
there's the transition year guys like
Eli - Daniel Jones and what do they do
with Ross burger and how does this work
with Philip Rivers but there's four
young guys that I find to be in a very
interesting situation Jared Goff dak
Mariota and Jameis all four of them
originally drafted by their teams all
for them at some point or not either a
member of the front office or the
coaches come out and said that's our
quarterback in the future with Jameson
Mariota it was implied both of these
guys are locks right now neither of them
are looks I feel more confident about
Jameis than I do about Mariota really
and I don't feel confident about James
why because there's some murmurs right
now in Tennessee that Tannehill is
looking comparable to Mariota and I
can't imagine what it's like to look at
a coach and go our franchise quarterback
and and possible future journeyman Ryan
Tannehill or that close maybe we don't
have one but with dak and Goff they're
both reliable they're both very good
quarterbacks but I don't know if either
team is really sure they're top ten
because they're not neither one of them
over top ten and they're arguably top 15
and it's gonna get
like they're right around there right
because Jared Goff is solid and he can
run an offense and the team loves him
and he's got a pretty good arm but on
the road his interception a touchdown
touchdown interception ratio goes from
22 to 4 to 11 to 10 he struggles in cold
weather like we saw in Chicago and he's
had moments like in the Superbowl where
you go this isn't gonna get it done
and with dak we've seen when he has
those 20 throws in a row where he can't
be accurate and while his legs are great
we know that there is a limited amount
of time for that and we sometimes wonder
what if we could do better than dak you
know I was thinking about golfing and
it's weird because there were times
where teams defensively allowing them to
go up and down a field fast break
offense really and then right around the
Eagles game maybe a couple games before
that they said ok this is what we're
gonna do we're gonna give you everything
underneath yeah so now you got a nickel
and dimed your way down the field and
teams started to do that and that's
consistent that offense was like we
don't know what to do that also
convinced me and through coincidence was
the same time that Todd Gurley started
to get falling apart and things like
that net offense just looked terrible
to your point they don't know if he can
carry the offense that's a big question
these teams that have been good for
years we're talking about Green Bay
kinda yeah we're talking about the
Patriots obviously lose people all the
time lose that Drew Brees and the Saints
they have one thing in common they have
a quarterback that can carry the team
whether you have a running game or not
people think I hit on Drew Brees
shout-out to Drew Brees who's been there
best number two wide receiver for like
the last three years Ted Ginn that's
right so he's really doing it with like
not a great wide receiving core but we
don't see that ethic he's doing it with
accuracy great play calling from Sean
Payton who I think is still one of the
damn Newton went 15 and one and like his
number two receiver was Jericho Khatri
this year you know I mean it's a-you
question golf - well I just wonder if he
can be consistent enough yeah patient
enough to take the small gains and say
listen I want to be accurate on every
throw not just the long ball I'm willing
to say you know what not they're checked
out and for us to win that way right I
don't know that he's able to do that we
saw that offense look high-flying last
year and then when the offense is caught
on they were like okay we're just gonna
back off play some zone Kevin
Clark had a really good art article for
the wringer where he was talking about
how the Chiefs even when Patrick mahomes
was a backup rookie began to completely
change the entire structure of their
front office by going we know he's our
quarterback of the future and we're
probably gonna have to pay him upwards
in the upper hundreds millions maybe in
two hundred million dollars and how they
said he's our guy let's adjust
everything I think it's interesting when
you see teams wait I don't even think
you need to listen to their quotes their
actions show they did not wait with
Carson Wentz they did not wait with
Patrick mahomes they do not they saw
Jimmy Garoppolo and a few practices and
I understood to sign him ups right the
Rams are waiting the Cowboys are waiting
the Bucks are waiting the Titans really
waiting though 30 million bucks for him
I'll say this that the number is between
30 and 32
I think the Cowboys like their
quarterback the most out of all of them
I mean I think I have faith in dak you
have to be a franchise I mean if we're
in order to win you have to have a
franchise quarterback and they also in
my opinion understand that it may take
them 10 years to find another one
reading into girly and what and and
Shaun McVeigh came out and said you know
we're taking it slow and all that but I
look and he practices one day he doesn't
practice the next what does this mean
from your view as someone that played
the position I'll take you back this is
an old history lesson I tore my ACL in
1996 stepped in
listen I'm in high school stepped in a
groundhog hole she twisted my knee we're
on as we were on some public we would we
were like in a park so you know that you
go to a park of Cordia swings and yeah
merry-go-round then and they have the
football field we're at a public park my
high school one of the best high schools
in the country has no practice field
really we don't have a game field either
we're practicing step into a groundhog
hole tear my terminal ACL right so I go
on to play have a couple more years in
college I play surgeries things like
that right in 2005-2006 you have to
start maintenance and different you
can't practice every single day you
go hard every single day it's worth at
the end of my career in Philadelphia
I was practicing one day a week on
Fridays and those are like half days
because what happens with your knee is
that they're pounding the constant
pounding if you don't have that the
cartilage without doubt that girly has
at this point he's had any issues you
have needs new issues they don't get
better they're constantly getting worse
every single every time you break a
tackle every time you make a move here
and there to shift to your left shift to
your right your lateral movement it gets
worse and worse and worse and so in my
mind if he's having these problems now
I'm just talking about from my yeah yeah
from my experience when you have these
problems especially early on in the
season because I'll say this early on in
the season you're the best you're ever
gonna be even with the bye week you're
still you're still hurting till midway
through the week and you're getting
better the last couple of days but
you're right back it goes right back
after the by 30 weeks does that normally
last what's that like that first like
I'm the best I'm gonna be all year like
well maybe so after like two three weeks
that's when we're gonna sense it and
unfortunately for for for girly his fear
not a physical runner like that but he's
big he's gonna get hit on his knees yes
he's gonna try to make peace go I'm
gonna take they gonna take his legs out
because he's a bigger guy I just think
that his knee is one of those things are
gonna get worse and worse and worse and
unfortunately for him towards the end of
the season when they need him the most
he'll be at the most unhealthiest that
he's been all season long that's a bad
position of being I just wonder why
teams that it's it's very public
knowledge right now that rotating backs
can kind of keep him healthy we see what
the Patriots to every year and the
Patriots what we laugh as we go who even
knew Jonas Gray was playing to 90s 200
yards rushing Bill Belichick's
philosophy is he cares at the running
back position who is the healthiest yeah
that's his number one thing not about
who's the best and what he does is he
saves people so he didn't really run
Sonia Michele that much at the end of
the regular season because he knew he
was gonna be a playoff back you know
what's up before that throughout the
regular season when he was healthy they
ran him into may ran at him 20 times a
game right there right before the
playoff all of a sudden you know did
that all of a sudden its we're gonna
dump off to James White 10 times
or really Rex Burkhead involved and they
do like almost a bullpen of running
backs now there are certain guys in this
league that I think are too special Zeke
is one of them se Kwan is one of them
David Johnson if he can be healthy levy
on bail we'll find out about chimera and
McCaffrey yeah but even chimera they're
putting him on like a like a not a snap
count they still wanted to get his
touches but they don't wanna be on the
field when he's not getting the touches
so that's why
but I look at these teams and I wonder
look man if you know you want Todd
Gurley maybe early because that's what
he's gonna feel the best and you just
drafted every Henderson and you got
Malcolm Brown like maybe I sit Gurley
three or four games in the middle of the
year if I'm a team that really thinks I
can make around the playoffs and you
have to manage it I would love to see I
mean I took sure he doesn't want to say
here's a hard part and I think they have
some backs that can back and weapon and
and Kawhi Leonard is on a you know I
mean does the same thing it's it's a
whole different world now and I'll tell
you even when I watched these preseason
games just almost ceiling guys and
getting arrest I doubt that any of the
good teams are gonna be playing their
players for an extended period of time
you know I saw Andy Reed played his guys
for a little bit there but I mean I'm
talking about they might not play at all
we're talking about Philadelphia
cause they may not play in the preseason
yeah and I'm like what are you talking
about he got hurt he wasn't active last
year he got hurt you're not gonna play
this kid but it also you're talking
about when coaches have jobs and whether
they have a job next year or not depends
on winning right they're gonna put all
their eggs in the basket listen I'm not
wasting you in pre-season right it has
to be a regular-season thing so I kind
of believe that III think that if I'm
the Rams and Sean McVeigh there are some
times where I'm saying listen you're not
gonna I'm not gonna not play you because
I want you to get your starts price some
incentives involve that contract but
there's some times where I'm you may
only get 10 carries a game that's that
yeah cuz we want to get these other guys
opportunities but we also want to rest
you because when we need you to most
last year yeah in the playoffs you were
and things weren't there
and even though Anderson had a great run
yes that's not sustainable and we all
know it's not something and so I look at
Gurley and I go throughout the year I
want you to get warmed up
every week as though you're playing no
doubt I want you to go through the
process I want you get ready on game day
I want you to stretch but I might not
use you and that's yeah not as much
don't have a problem with that but it's
it just sucks you would have a problem
if you're talking early you have
infinitives in your contract though
that's the problem that would be the
only issue and unless you're saying
listen I'm gonna get however many
guarantee bucks so it really doesn't
matter yeah but the only issue that you
would had if you're talked early is that
if I got some Pro Bowl incentives if I
have some Russian yard incentives right
at a million dollars and I'm at eight
hundred and fifty yards with two games
left and you're telling me I'm gonna sit
then I got some problems preseason games
rookies any any rookies that you saw or
young guys or anyone that kind of jumped
out to you that you said you know what I
want to buy low on this guy so I watched
the Johnny's game right okay oh yeah man
Daniel Giants fans went from boo and
Daniel James they got a savior yeah I
think he mean I think Pat did a good job
had summer their hands I think he did a
good job it really when I looked across
the league even with Conor Mary Mary
they did a good job of getting him plays
that he could be confident yes Josh
Roshan rosin down in Miami they gave him
some plays that allowed him to build
some confidence I even thought even
though he threw a pick six
I thought Dewayne Askins played great
I'll tell you this and I was I was in of
course I'm from Washington and I was
down there watching the game and I think
that he has a lot of talent so this is
what's so strong
this is what's so funny that you guys
can be good football fans if you just go
to youtube and you're gonna NFL and you
just write type in every Dwayne Haskins
throne and if you want to be one of
those people that watch his SportsCenter
and you see a pick six and go well that
was bad nothing I'm just letting you
know there was like three or four plays
where Haskins like knocked a linebacker
on the ground and then uncorked a
40-yard laser and I said Trent Williams
isn't out there none of the wide
receivers around there this team's a
mess but those are plays that nobody
else could do daniel Jones couldn't do
that well this is what you get in task
is a big athlete physical in lie barn
I'm telling me this guy kid throws a
football
so I was gonna get to him but let's
start there I think all the coaches did
a good job of protecting the quarterback
play-action pass get them out on the
edge so they give you throw it away or
run hopefully not or get them an easy
dump all pass when you watch Schuyler
marry first couple place three steps out
so he's catching the ball out of the
shotgun not really a hard read the
defensive back is off the off the
receiver three steps boom balls out of
my hand great option slang yeah we'd
option slant right and so and a lot of
the things were to the outside for Conor
Mary some of the quarterbacks you want
to give them to going towards the inside
so you could see it right in their face
yeah but I mean the coaches did a great
job that's why I mentioned dangling oh
that thing Pat did a great job of
getting them confident and that's what
you want to do first preseason game I'm
not playing any my real starters right
but I want to get these young
quarterbacks in particular some
confidence so that now the second
preseason game you're gonna see
different style of defense it's gonna be
a little bit harder those guys that were
open last week they're not gonna be open
this week but now you had that
confidence that hey I can complete balls
in the NFL that was in I even went back
and watched every throw of Drew Locke
because they just had their second one
and he looked better for Denver yes he
liked the first game that he had on the
Hall of Fame game he did not look good
at all prompting Vic Fangio to be like
no he looked awful but in against Miami
are not Miami whoever Denver played he
looked a lot better in that game I love
and I'm a little bit obsessed with Kyle
armories look I don't think he's got the
little bandana tails coming out the back
he's so much shorter than he's been
telling everybody was there the visor
always in shotgun
cannon for an arm came and he starts
running and people look like they're in
slow motion um the the look of Kyler
he looks so [ __ ] I was impressed that
mean listen you saw with Vic guys f
athletes right Lamar Jackson to really
during the regular season and the
preseason last year when you're athlete
your fail your failsafe is always just
run yeah use your legs
at no point the counter Murray even
consider running get the ball out of my
hands I'm a passer congratulations to
him maybe it again five eight five nine
maybe get the ball out of my hands
pocket passer
that's impressive to me I even look at
guys like Lamar Jackson I thought this
year the Ravens would run the ball a
thousand times but Lamar actually looked
good didn't run the ball at all you know
again I oh I always have to take it all
in preseason first preseason game basic
beef if you see some blitzes things like
that but nothing nothing too crazy
that's like I saw the the one nice throw
from Lamar Jackson was it was a great
scheme a tight end came across and
created like a flow concept and so yeah
he completed the pass but I was like
nobody else is doing that in pre-season
other than Baltimore but Daniel Jones
what he did more importantly then throw
a touchdown was he looked somewhat like
a quarterback he had the nice touch on
the one across the middle he had the
nice touch either thing about Daniel
Jones also is he's not afraid to throw
it into a crowd which I appreciate about
him do I believe that that's all I need
to see about enough absolutely not
absolutely not
I think he has a long way to go however
we need to mean this is weird because
you don't get this when you're young I'm
talking about a young player the
preseason is really all you got so I got
to show these coaches out yes as you get
older the importance of the preseason
especially to the team that's going to
be playing right is less that's why
that's why everyone's returning kicks
from like oh they need to get on Tech's
right so of course I think a lot of
people have put a lot of emphasis on
this first game because that's all we
have do we yes we have a hunger for
football and this is all we have I think
that these first games are great
confidence boosters you could ruin a guy
to let me go out there and get sacked
three or four times and see what he does
in xk-- sure he's gonna be shotgun I
mean shell shocked and scared every time
he touches the ball
I think these coaches did a great job
when I look at these guys are you gonna
win your job in the preseason for some
of these guys yeah but also daniel Jones
guys like that even Josh Rosen who may
or may not start behind Fitzpatrick down
there in Miami at least you can see what
he can do yes this you can say okay you
know what I can build on that I just
remember small things like Andy Reid
seeing things in preseason oh I didn't
know you could run that around let me
let me scheme up some things that can
make you more useful in the regular
season you can see what these young guys
to do what are the things that you fall
back on third and three out route for
Kylie very easy money
he saw that already these are the small
things we saw the same thing with Daniel
John strong arm doing asking strong arm
put him in a rollout situation he kind
of looked like Doug Williams really when
I'm watching that guy just how big is
big physical strong arm he made some bad
decisions they're doing Haskins made
some okay really Tex one was just he
just didn't touch it right he like oh he
was wide open but and then the other
throw he just overthrew were thrown in
that happens yeah to me that's nothing
no for a young quarterback so it was
good to see these young guys get
involved and you look for athletes like
I watched the bear so I see Montgomery
and I know he's a baller I look at the
Chiefs I see me call Hardman I go that's
a lot of [ __ ] speed we're talking
about building plays I mean I can't
imagine this is what Andy Reed told me
we're going into the summer we pick up
Mike Vick right and I was excited Mike
Vicks come out you know the anniversary
of that is ten years ago tomorrow is it
the so August well it's gonna be Tuesday
August 13th is the 10 year anniversary
of Vicks I need Eagles what the mean it
seems like yesterday it makes me feel
worse because now I'm getting older and
older apparently what happened when he
signed so Andy I'm talking to Andy in
the hallway he's like yeah we're gonna
get Vick I'm like okay that's what's up
I mean you're thinking about Michael
Vick seven running around the field the
Michael Vick is spirit may you remember
the commercials worse and so he's like
you know so he spends his offseason in
California on the beach Andy does this
is funny because see you Andy on the dog
a [ __ ] is the whole different story but
he said I drew up all these plays he
said he had to be napkins were for plays
Wow that he drew up from Vick and I'm
looking at the young kid was at Hartman
for a vehicle harbor for Chiefs of
Chiefs and when you see that type of
speed you combine that with to reek Hill
what is an T out there doing now he's
drawing up plays on napkins again
because you can't teach that so Andy's
one of those guys that when he gets a
piece o you excitement is so much
he just starts beautiful mind relief is
like a little kid yeah like doodling
like a little kid but he's drawing plays
and he would come up to you and just be
like hey I just drew up a great one yeah
yeah this is we're gonna do its you're
gonna go in motion and you're gonna do
this and then we're gonna piss the ball
here then you're gonna go I'm like coach
come on this off season has been the ODA
Sean McVeigh that Zach Taylor got a job
and got the floor got a job in Shaw
McVeigh and then he came from Kyle
Shanahan that's the new offense but
there's been this other wave on the
Internet of Andy Reid's the best
offensive mind the NFL and it's been
coming up through Twitter I've been
seeing it and and people are going
everyone says that McVeigh makes Gough
why doesn't read make mahomes and then
they show the plays and you see all
these and these amazing opportunities is
Andy Reid up there in terms of best
offensive minds and would you even be
willing to say he's the best in the NFL
I'm thinking about office of my
obviously Bay I think we Daniels 1,000%
I think my top four typically is McVeigh
McDaniels Sean Payton and Kyle Shanahan
look I have been disrespecting Amy Reed
and I kind of think we should be over
that's why all those other guys are we
like good leader he's a Kingsbury pop
your collar
that's when Andy Reid's over there look
like a former offensive lineman look
like the offensive lineman but he he
knows how to coach guys we talk about
managing personalities knows how to do
that very well he knows how to allow his
quarterback to play the game but all
during the week I'm teaching you and I'm
building your confidence all throughout
the week part of building your
confidence as a quarterback and and this
is just the way it is you want to
challenge the guys during practice but
you also want them to be right you know
I'm saying so as if it's cover to over
here and man-to-man over here I want my
quarterback to understand that I don't
want you to throw to the corporate cover
to side to the right and get the ball to
the left side the man-to-man I just want
you to see it then I want you to
complete the ball that's important how
you practice is important just as
important as how you play in the game
because this is how I build your
confidence so that now when you go into
the game you're this animal that has
never been defeated before so you're
confident Patrick Mahone's they'll throw
any ball up there and know that your
receiver is gonna be there
that's the type of animal that Andy
rebuilds he builds that through his
practice in his repetition and how he
teaches he's young I feel like he gets
to use his full offense with my homes
and I don't think with McNab and Alec
Smith he was able to it feels like now
he can really uncork it well I think I
think Patrick Mahone's and when you
compare it to McNab talent lies
I think arm Talent
Mahone's probably has a little bit more
right now I think McNab was probably
just as athletic I think he had an arm
strength just the same but as far as the
refine passing part my homes probably is
a little bit better yes you also have to
understand Donovan except for those year
and a half of T Oh Todd Pinkston James
thrash everybody's like these are just
guys that de Bain Douglas your Damian
Douglas somebody these are just guys I
mean these are all my good friends but
hey Smith they're not to rekindle yeah
thank me we just didn't have that same
type of talent and so it's a bit
different you know and so when Andy now
he's like listen I got the arm talent I
got a good running back in the backfield
and I got some guys out here Kelsey Hill
Hardman that can go get it and if you
have that I'm it's it's hard to stop you
know that people are saying that the
chief softens gonna take a step back
this year I think I mean they couldn't
they're wrong I think they put up some
huge numbers I think they put a huge
number you think they can get better I
don't think I think it's very hard to
improve on a 5050 touchdown season and I
also think that they took a step back at
running back and no one wants to talk
about it because they don't want to get
into the domestic violence of cream hunt
but like Damian Williams and Carlos Hyde
or maybe when you play good last year
when he had a chance to play good but I
think that cream hunt is like there's a
reason why it Browns camp right now
they're like in week 10 we're getting
him back like I've talked to some of
their guys like they can't believe it
but with with the Chiefs a lot of it I
think comes down to the health of the
offensive line too and I also think that
their offense was so good last year
partially because their defense was so
bad they kept getting like necessity
recesses they had to shoot out but now
with Frank Clark and honey badger and
Darren Lee like I
defense will be a little bit better but
I still think they're gonna put up
numbers
I don't think Pat Ramones getting
stopped at all this year there's always
a fear and you say you've rookie and
that not because that Patrick mahomes
was a rookie last year second year guy
really this first year plane so a lot of
times teams especially you dab it they
adjust they don't think it's happening
bro it's hard to adjust the arm talent
check Belichick played him twice mm-hmm
so Belichick had game footage heading up
to that first game and then when
Belichick plays a guy twice in the same
season they pretty much get destroyed
and he put up over 35 points both games
I don't think he's someone that you can
game plan because I think he can throw
it further than your defense and I think
the offense is too strong I don't think
he's game plan at all well that's what
you said Rodgers arm talent arm talent
is like I don't care if I have Aaron
Rodgers if I have a run game I don't
care Drew Brees if I got a run game I
just need me I just need this right
shoulder that's all I need and with that
I can win period yeah I don't care who
you put out there in Andy Reid
fortunately enough for him you know Tom
a bag of wishes you got Kelsey
that's tight in the league tarik he'll
one of the most explosive players in the
league don't forget Sammy Watkins Sammy
Watkins debo Samuels is there no no he's
on the Niners call Hardman no uh Sammy
Watkins Miko Harmon is there a they have
a bunch of guys they got this guy
Robinson that's really good to me they
have so many guys um what do you think
about Myles Sanders have you got a
chance like watch him at all I've seen
them a bunch I think sorry egocentric of
me I need you yeah quick switch back to
the Eagles man just go always get back
to the Eagle it always comes back to the
you I think mile Sanders is gonna get a
bunch of opportunities this year I don't
know and I'm going back to last year I
don't know how Jordan Howard fits in
this offense I think they want to run
the ball a bunch I think they will run
the ball a lot specially to protect
Carson and I think mouths Anders fits
what they want to do better than Jordan
Howard just solely based on what I saw
from Jordan Howard last year it didn't
seem like he was interested there was
times where I'm saying of course he
didn't fit you know that Nagy's offense
but it said it felt like he didn't want
to fit it either and he
looked a little heavy to me Jordan
Howard in my mind fits the LeGarrette
Blount and what they were hoping Josh
Adams could be last year a bruiser
which was were up ten and we want to
punch in the mouth that's right that's
right or or its third and one and Josh
Adams had the fumbling problem last year
and LeGarrette Blount was that guy that
you know end of the game against the
Chargers busts out the 60 I run middle
of the game against the Patriots in the
Super Bowl
40-yard touchdown two and and every sir
I've ever read about read about Jordan
Howard it's his shoulders falling off
and he's still gonna play and then Kyle
long comes out after the game and is
like I would do anything for Jordan
Howard I don't think the Eagles have
really had that guy they had glimpse of
it with LeGarrette Blount but Howard's
more in his prime but I agree I think
Sanders this offense if you can put him
out there with two tight ends and now
you have all these wide receivers with
the Eagles whether it's a Shanda Shawn
or thing out Whiteside I I really only
need miles out there Howard is my
bruiser in the in the red zone and this
may sound a little weird because this
guy this name I'm about to throw out
there he did it he only had a cup of
coffee in Philadelphia but remember Jay
is dying of course he's a free agent
writing hard when he was healthy yeah
when the Falcons came week one look good
when he was healthy when he was right I
think mile Sanders gonna be like that
number 16 I think he can run physically
I think he could be shifty I think that
get handling the ball 15 times 16 times
a game and he could be very productive I
think he'd be that guy but especially
when you talk about you put them in 12
personnel one running back to tight ends
defensively what do you do if you go big
then you get beat by the pass routes by
Goddard come out there Nertz you can't
you can't put three linebackers on the
field right yes so you got to go nickel
some teams will say I'm gonna go dime I
don't care so if you go nickel let's say
you got two linebackers in the game and
a cornerback in if four down linemen
well we're just gonna run the football
yeah so we're gonna do we're gonna
spread you out I'm gonna run the
football and see if that one linebacker
can make it can make a play and for the
first time if the Eagles go al Sean
Deshawn Goddard Earths
and Sanders they can truly do whatever
they want and they finally have a wide
receiver that can stretch a deep and is
a real threat yeah
we admit threat didn't not that I
believe that DeSean Jackson also brings
a swagger that the Eagles haven't had in
years ever had it all light yeah it's
all been like Jordan Matthews and that
I'm not taking shots but everybody goes
but now DeSean Jackson is like nah fam
this is how I get down yes but this is
this is actually to your point I'm a
little bit concerned about the office
because of that not because of his
swagger things like that I don't know
that they have a backup to the Sean
Jackson oh that's what can really
concerns we know that DeSean misses
games he'll miss you missed three or
four games and not saying anything his
shoulder and Mack Honus hasn't been
healthy you know I don't know that he's
even practicing at this point who is a
team that made the playoffs last year
that you're going I don't think they're
gonna make it again this year last year
that made it mine is the Texans what
really yeah Texans well I think the
Texans had the easiest schedule in the
NFL last year yeah and when you look at
the quarterbacks they faced it wasn't
good and then when they played one they
collapsed I think their offensive line
is a mess I think that Jadeveon Clowney
is kind of holding out so well you don't
think he comes back no no he's gonna
play right but I just I think that I
didn't they take a step back I think the
Jaguars take a step up and I think the
Colts keep playing well well I would
tell me what makes you take the Jaguars
gonna take that team look terrible I
look at the Jaguars and I see a team
that you believe in Nick pho they had a
ton of injuries and I think that usually
that that regresses to the mean so I
think that offensive lines can be a
little bit healthy for net missed and a
number of games Blake bortles stinks so
Nick Foles brings them up and I think
that defense is still really really good
my only hope is that Jalen Ramsey
doesn't start looking to play for the
Titans mid-year mess them up but I think
the Jaguars will be back in the seven
and nine eight and eight teams so with
that being said Tennessee is I mean the
Texans are out I think so
Colts win the division Colts win a
division yeah and the Jaguars are one of
like us are fighting with the Jets the
bills all the teams the a I've seen
yeah because I don't know who's winning
that one and then like whoever the
secondary team is in the West I'm gonna
say it's probably the chargers for a
while the wild-card teams I'm thinking
and I'm looking at him here I had to
pull them up and I think the Saints or
the Rams one of those teams doesn't make
the playoffs really yeah it's always
hard to go against Drew Brees I think
the Rams make it but I think the Rams
may I think Seattle's gonna be good I
think so too I think that the Rams may
be the wild-card I think the Chicago
Bears because I believe yeah I believe
that the Vikings at some point I just
believe they're gonna figure it out and
I don't know why I believe in Diggs and
cook and feeling and for some reason I
like Kirk Cousins and I don't know why I
do too
I think that the the Vikings will be
much better I think Green Bay is a
little division funk me I don't think
he's even a funk with the coach between
it LeFleur writing the quarterback I
think it's just you know the media
playing games again I think Chicago may
be in the short end of the stick there
again I think it's hard for teams and
defenses to understand what a team was
gonna do when you have a brand new head
coach I'm also wondering this is a this
is kicker news so it's not that big but
the Ravens had his kicker car Yvette
Vick yeah yeah and he apparently was
banging out 50 he kicked 53 and 58
against the Jacksonville Jaguars but
made all four and the Vikings traded for
ya and the Reich the Vikings
this is like a 2 per for me one he can
kick and punt and I've never seen
someone do that both on a team very
maybe save a roster spot but you know
what else it did it prevented him from
going to the Bears and the Bears it's
defining their camp being in in burr
talked about all the time about Panero
versus Frye and who's gonna win and
madero missed a kick and and you take
maybe the number one other kick her off
the market from your other team I think
the Bears take a step back this year
also there are the Bears were last year
where they were going away from brothers
and their reports right now that try
Biscay is not looking that great in
training camp
I'd like to Biscay but he also he was
not that great list no no that offense
listen last year tarik Coleman was
awesome mazing I mean he was listening I
mean it was really
cool to see what he's doing I'm
wondering if he can carry that over for
another year
I think the Bears if I had to pick one
is probably that one team that falls out
of the playoffs again I can't see the
Green Bay Packers not making a playoff
two years in a row right I agree and
then you and like you said the Vikings
are right up there and I would say the
Lions should take a step up this year -
when I say step up I mean if they won
four games last year they win six I
think but they they improve but I think
that the defense's can be a lot better
with all the guys they got with Trey
flowers and all that it's a new offense
with Stafford but I think they're gonna
give it more to carry on Johnson the
offense was better I just think they
have to improve I'm gonna make a
statement and I think you're gonna get
angry at me okay
I don't I don't think the gap between
Donovan McNabb and Kirk Cousins is that
big what do you mean I don't think is I
am about to get mad yeah but I don't
think Donovan abs that much better than
your crazy
let me tell you why I'm ask you a
question how many how many years has how
many times have the Kirk Cousins been in
the playoffs he got to the playoffs one
two maybe two I'll look at let's just
say - the question for Donovan McNabb
season after season was never will you
make the playoffs that was that wasn't
even in the conversation it's a team
game though your defense was amazing
yeah so what and you the bike is that
one of the best defenses - they have a
really good defense so what I'm not
talking about I'm just almost stats wise
no no I'm talking about them as players
and then you're doing that then you're
absolutely right I will get mad and I
think you're crazy what do you mean do
you know why I think it's clothesline
because I think Kirk Cousins is getting
every ounce of his potential and I don't
think that Donovan used all of his
potential
I think Donovan naturally is a better
player than Kirk cause okay but because
Kirk maximized and I don't think Donovan
maximized I don't think the gap is that
big I think it could have been that gate
do you remember the year when Donovan
McNabb came in absolutely shredded yeah
I don't I don't think it ever happened
that's what I'm saying listen he like I
always thought that Donovan McNabb came
in like and damn I didn't want to get
into this
let me stop it please did Kirk what team
did Kirk Cousins inherit that were
terrible and he brought him out of that
he had the one year where he almost took
Washington the playoffs with Shawn I
heard you say so hard to say an
important word in there and this is the
turning point you don't leave that
Donnell McNab ever carry the Eagles by
himself there's no doubt about milestone
what do you let me ask you this who was
the wide receivers I like Todd Pinkston
yeah that's my yeah top picks is a good
friend of mine I like him too
yeah but who was he dealing know if he
digs no no no so easy all I know is is
that I know that Andy Reed used to have
parts of the PlayBook that was you and
LJ Smith that's right and I thought that
you two were were really [ __ ] good
well we were but Donovan was a big part
of that I know it teams respecting his
legs and his arm will you agree with me
that he didn't reach his potential
though I think Donovan this is my
opinion out there and I think he has to
want to do this too I think he probably
could have played another five six years
and I think he could have started and I
also think he could have been a backup
for another five six years if he wanted
to do this right I think he got out of
the league prematurely I think there's a
lot of things that go into that yes but
I also think that as a team not just
Donovan as a team we probably
underachieved
because we had we had really good talent
and we had a leader we had a good coach
as you guys have a question Andy Reid's
time management I think the media
question is the question as a player I
never I mean it wasn't it wasn't my
place to question that as a play now
that you're done yeah now that I'm late
you probably did some things differently
we can try one couple games differently
right but I also felt that the end of
the game didn't necessarily tell the
whole story of the game that there
probably was some plays in the second
quarter that we could have done too
short or I could have done a better job
blocking in a third call I don't think
that era was a disappointment I thought
it was [ __ ] awesome I thought so too
but when you but what happens is when
you win a Super Bowl in 2017 they forget
about what happened from from 99 to 2000
[ __ ] that
that era like this that the super
bowl-winning Eagles team was very calm
compared to your era and I think we look
at the Jason Kelsey speech afterwards
and Lane Johnson's comments about the
Patriots and it adds a lot more color to
it and and look you have Malcolm Jenkins
and and but but Carson and Nick Foles
are kind of vanilla you know I mean like
Jordan Matthews was like vanilla and and
I look at those teams and I think about
trot and Douglas and Dawkins and you and
and the personalities and Freddie and
and Jon Runyan you know and and Hollis
Thomas you just look at all of them and
you're like I don't know that that was
it was like my first date it's weird
because when I look at this team that
won the Superbowl a couple years ago
underdogs I mean they lived off of that
lived it
there was no saw where the favorites
every [ __ ] year Sports Illustrated
picked you guys to win every [ __ ]
that was that was that's but I in my
opinion obviously we had a really good
defense we had some might will you
obviously have one Hall of Fame because
we had some really good players to
insert on the taxes out of the hearse
for a little bit but part of me
understands and believed that Donovan
was the thing that made that thing go
offensive ly and I mean and I watched a
game in the vet where he broke his ankle
and threw four touchdowns against the
Arizona claim this sucker just kept on
going back on tape it up I saw I'm gonna
tape it up tape it up tape put up on the
vet that's like playing on top of his
table
yeah tape it up and he went and played
everything he did and this is Donovan as
a friend he was a professional they
attacked him in a lot of different ways
that a lot of people don't get attacked
they they try to do everything to to say
the black quarterback and this and that
and not smart and all he has the
athleticism and he became a better
pocket passer I'm gonna retire my
Donovan takes after today all right
you told me that last time I came here
you told me that no I didn't I just were
you were thinking it at least I was just
walking to work today I thought about
Kirk Cousins like he's not how much that
last thing for you is who do you think
is the best running back in the NFL
right now he had to pick one so I think
it's I mean and I got a Posie kin it I
think it's between Zeke and say Kwan in
in and I think cámaras whereas
right there - right and so III I think
pure running back a god is gonna run the
ball a bunch I would pick sake Wow I
think sake was less running back because
me he has the same ability if not a
little bit more a little bit faster than
Z but he also is gonna spread you out of
catch the ball even though I'm talking
about Zika at 77 catches last yeah so I
would go say Quan I would I would not
feel in any way disappointed if I have
Zika my team now well of camara now
that's a different story now this he is
a Ferrari down there and there are so
many different things different use I'm
wondering how it's gonna work out
without having an Ingram back there with
him yes but we whatever you want to do
with him put them put him wherever man
and he's that he's that guy my own I
have one more I lied
the Trent Williams situation I know
you're close to Washington it came out
today from a tweet from former
Washington Redskins ooook Ravens
who was there for like a little bit but
he said two years later and I'm still
fighting the skins on something they
continue to do countless times
mishandled injuries and withheld
information all evidence points to them
being guilty the story of people don't
realize and I know we've talked about a
lot Trent Williams the the main story is
now midway through the year he goes to
the training staff and says I got a bump
on my head what the [ __ ] mm-hm and they
go you're fine it's not a big deal after
the season he gets it looked at it's a
tumor yeah it's the disease of doubt
once I doubt you
I can never not doubt you again and
they've said he's not publicly asked us
for money he's not asked us to fire the
medical staff the auditor he just wants
to leave I've never seen this before
well because Zeek wants money for two
months money let me I wants money he
wants to go well here's the thing as a
player there's not a lot of guys that
you can just trust but there's one staff
that you have to be able to trust
without doubt that you're gonna look out
from our best interest whether it's the
best interest of the team or not
I have to believe that the training
staff is gonna say Brian we want you to
play but the truth is that your ankle is
really messed up and you probably could
play but it's not in your best
trista play or Trent Williams we're
gonna take a look at this bump on your
head and I don't care if our quarterback
gets hit a million times
you're not playing until we figure out
exactly what this is because their
season is already over and guess what
we're gonna take care of you because
we're concerned about you the man and we
were expecting you to wear a Washington
jersey and the Hall of Fame and you get
inducted because for the last eight
years you haven't missed a Pro Bowl oh
and by the way it's bigger than the game
and I know nobody wants to hear that the
team's don't want to say that but it
really is and the guys have to believe
that in trust because at some point
you're gonna go to the trainer you're
gonna say listen my ankles hurt and you
want the trainer to say well you know
what you can't do any more damage to
your ankle and you have to believe that
because as a pray you're gonna go out
there and play it they tell you that and
I gotta trust you in it that you're
telling me the truth are they gonna be
able to sign a free agent after this
come back to the money question we'll
say I'll pay for my own doctor it's your
trip Williams I'm out so I'll say this
your Trent Williams did there's no going
back
do you think he plays a game with
Washington ever again no wow here's the
other thing if you're the Redskins why
would you want them to I would trade
them in a minute okay you don't want to
be here you know what we're not gonna
win anyway there's the problem the top
three teams that are rumored to be
interested in
Trent Williams the Patriots you might be
sending them to win a Super Bowl
so the Browns you might be setting them
to win a Super Bowl and they become the
team of cast-off NFC East players Odell
Beckham and Trent Williams or you said
them to the Texans that's the one that
makes sense to read IFC teams can guess
what if you give me my asking price I
don't care if you win we're not gonna
win anyway we're not gonna win whip him
Texans just gave up possibly if he plays
enough snaps a third-round pick for Duke
Johnson they shouldn't eat that's a bad
move instantly giving up a first-round
pick for true well here's a deal if
you're to walk the Washington Redskins
you're not gonna win anyway
with or without him straight up so it
doesn't really matter if he's there or
not you're not gonna win three of those
teams all three of those teams are AFC
teams so it's not necessarily not having
them to your division or your conference
so it really doesn't matter in that way
I want to know who has the best package
that I get some drought
some money that's what I want that if
I'm the risk in but you don't see them
ever playing again and it's time for
Washington to move on
I don't regain my trust in that man that
told me that this thing that could have
been a worst-case scenario cancerous yes
there's nothing I can't how do I trust
you can you imagine something big like
that that's this is huge this is
important to me I can't trust you any
more than an ankle sprain no this isn't
this is even bigger than Kevin Durant
and you know what all you had to do is
check it out that's how you all I had to
do check it out just check it out
because I came to you and made a big
deal of it and all you have to do is
check it out and what you didn't do is
do your one job you had one job to check
it out that's your job now I've just
like you said I busted my butt made
countless promos for us as a team and
we've been terrible my entire career in
Washington and this is how you treat me
I blocked for Colt McCoy multiple times
this is how you treat me I'm blocked for
Kirk Cousins and rg3 NFL's supposed to
be the best in so many areas if I'm true
Williams I can't play for them no more
damn I'm not treated like the best
anymore it's over I'm out of there all
right Westbrook you're the [ __ ] man
anything else do you want to say to the
people of Earth and when I said in the
beginning that you're the greatest
Eagles running back of all time I mean
that I appreciate so when you talk about
time to not having weapons bro he had
you you had like 80 catches and seasons
again hard knocks
Tuesday night if it doesn't go well it
could be dead I am gonna be in LA
working on some things for the new show
which I have been able to announce yet
so my hope is I'm gonna record a short
solo pod maybe a number is gonna come on
from Rams camp but I'm gonna only be
talking about hard knocks so it'd be
like a 20 30 minute episode coming out
on Thursday love you all up from be west
on the lef koe
man and we will holla holla holla at you
guys later be wilder than
[Music]